I started the baby-sitters club to take
care of kids but what I realize we were
more than a club we were best friends
you guys have so much style on the show
and in real life it's so good and the
premiere is coming up so you both have
to be so excited but how familiar were
you with these books before you actually
started this series so my mom had always
referred to herself as being a dawn and
so of course I was younger I was like
who the heck is dawn so I did my
research I did a lot of research and I
figured out about we have this big box
of the old baby-sitters Club books in
the garage so I stumbled across them and
it was honestly like a story like a
fairy tale book ending and I have fallen
in love with them and they're definitely
one of my favorite book series your mom
and I have so much in common because I
was a mad baby-sitters club family I
don't know my age but no what about you
so G what about you how did you were you
into the books at all or did you get
into him before the show when Netflix
first announced that they were gonna be
doing a baby-sitters club I was like
okay well let's I want to be part of
this and my mom started digging on eBay
and finding the books and getting as
many as she could and once they came to
the house of course I just read them and
I started reading and I started watching
I watched the TV series and the movie
and I have to say I really enjoyed it
ah and here you gals are you are now a
part of this club not only like you know
in a sake of a friendship in real life
but like for Netflix that's pretty cool
so have you gained some cool points with
your friends at all because now you're
part of a Netflix series well for me I
feel like my friends have like you know
they don't really like to talk about it
because they're like oh she's on the
Netflix show okay well um I don't know
what to do with that you know uh but
it's I feel like it's really important
for them to know that I'm still the same
person and that we're friends no matter
what
absolutely what about you Julia do your
friends treat you any differently you're
heavy scored some major cool points with
them because now you're on Netflix uh
some people home like drifted away did
support me before so it's okay because
like it's okay
um but some people have like come back
to me since like kindergarten I got some
like kindergarten friends for me I was
in your class I'm sick oh right I
definitely remember that for sure um but
I feel like my closest friends they have
definitely stuck beside me the whole
time they have been my grounding points
and they've been so lovely and so
supportive and they're very excited for
me so I'm very grateful to have them
that's awesome and what I love about
this series I thought you guys did a
phenomenal job and the episodes I was
able to see I can't wait to see the last
one but they're keeping me you know on
the edge of my seat well you know being
inclusive and being friends it really is
at the heart of it it's about friendship
so how did you all find over you know
the sake of shooting this series how we
will able to bond on set and did you
bond off set and have you been able to
communicate with one another since we've
all been in quarantine now I feel very
start of the first time the last
audition when we all told we got cast as
the baby-sitters club we exchanged phone
numbers and we facetimed and we texted
like almost every day and I feel like
that was a great like foundation for a
bonding point but when we finally met in
person again I feel like it was just so
natural and we became friends like God
you clicked so well and of course
forming these bonds with these girls was
gonna be a little easier because they're
all my age and we all have a lot of
shared interests and I feel like that's
a leverage for us I guess um yeah I feel
like we've definitely connected we're
all like our own little BSc family yeah
what about you said you have you guys
been able to like maintain communication
with each other since you've now wrapped
filming and you know the series is about
to come out for everyone to see so have
you all been in touch with one another
during quarantine we keep in touch with
FaceTime you know group chats and social
media but like Malia said we were told
at the test on our final you know
audition that we were the baby-sitters
club and that is actually very rare kids
usually don't get all that they get
they're cast on like on one of the first
days and so I feel like having you know
having that information I'm getting to
you know share each other's it look in
for me like you know numbers really help
it really like she said it it grew round
ation and where later on now it's like
we know so much about each other and to
the point where it's like oh my gosh
okay where do I even start
you know clearly at the baby-sitters
club the heart of it you guys obviously
is friendship
but you also do babysitting and a lot of
it and you make it look so fun and easy
but in real life do you guys have a lot
of babysitting experience yes I did the
babysitter's test when I was in grade
six and we learned a lot about some
stuff some of it reaching yeah I was
like I need to learn about internal
bleeding while I'm babysitting but we
learned a lot of stuff a lot of medical
stuff as well and I definitely think I'm
prepared for anything sitting jobs in
the future I've been babysitting my
sister I don't know forever now so
experience from kids around my block so
definitely I love babysitting her cool
so it comes in handy for the job and so
she what about you do you have any
babysitting experience in real life
young lady not much baby is like I did
in the in the show but mostly you know
toddlers but you know there there aren't
too many of those in my hood um but you
know I get to pets in a lot hey those
are you know baby to a lot of folks my
pup is my baby so hey I'll take it well
ladies congratulations the series was
awesome and I wish you to continue to
success and I know I'm gonna see your
stars shining in the future so just keep
on keepin on alright thank you so much
it's nice oh I mean it take care okay
fine
[Music]